do you find that there's any implication
for quantum computing or
or your research in general and the
problem of p equals np
or is there no relation yeah yeah no no
absolutely
um so yeah like
on the question of p equals mp um
the fact that p equals mp hasn't been
proved
has is like
it it's like one of the base assumptions
of quantum complex not quantum rather um
computational complexity
and the fact that it hasn't proved been
proved means that like basically nothing
else can be proved
um so like for example a quantum
computer is better than classical
computers
we have lots of evidence to suggest yes
but we can't prove
it because if we could prove it um then
we would already be able to prove that p
doesn't equal mp because
um well at least for decision problems
like if we could find a so
there's like you know in the decision
problem hierarchy there's this p
and then there's like np which we think
is bigger um
but if we could even find one problem
that is definitely in np and not in p
right we would you know prove that p
doesn't equal mp but
for quantum computing to be better than
um uh than
um classical computing we we would have
to
like and to be able to prove that we'd
have to find a problem outside of p
that um a quantum computer can solve but
if that problem existed
um it probably is inside of np and so
we've probably already improved p equals
mp
um and so yeah like it is a first step
to proving that quantum computers are
better than classical computers
and a first step to many things in
quantum in computational complexity
which
like yeah all all depend on on assuming
that's true
so prime factorization that's an np
correct
um yes but it is not a hundred percent
proved to not be in p that's the problem
i see i see
so in fact no np problems have been
proved to definitely not be in p
okay as far as i know there's a
difference between np problems and then
np
complete problems is that okay so is the
prime factorization np complete or just
np just mp
okay okay okay yeah yeah certainly it's
certainly not complete because we
don't suspect that quantum computers can
solve np complete problems